les bâtiments bbc les dans un instant on
va savoir tout ce que pensent les gens
la pratique de veau et des chroniqueurs
tout d'abord 50 secondes qu'est ce qui
se passe on voit tout ce qui ce fait
j'adore ça quand tu roules insight opep
est parti c'est bien tous et bienvenue
dans sa carte green side bmp on commence
tout de suite avec l'allocution
officielle et cyril hanouna certainement
tex et quand le public danse regarder
comment ça montiel dans son slip à
bernard
[Applaudissements]
le chat
hello world du suce boules de l'année
est attribué à nicolas pernikoff
pourtant ça n'a rien à dire s'il est
toujours aussi sérieux pendant les
débats regardez-moi ça mais plutôt les
terrasses parce qu'on craignait qu'à
l'intérieur les gens ne se contaminent
et donc vous voyez bien que enfermer les
gens n'a absolument aucun effet
productif et que je passe mon temps à
vous de lire ici il ya maintenant 5 6 et
vous vouliez savoir pourquoi guillaume
genton était aussi aimable avec les
compteurs linky
regardez les complotistes en fait si tu
me dis que c'est un conteur pour nous
espionner c'est plus un compteur pour
mieux estimer notre consommation
[Musique]
les petits filous cyril et kelly qui
font exprès de taille et benjamin kayzer
corps par la crainte et la tête et
épaules
en fait il ya plus rien
rensing une fixée chez
[Rires]
t'inquiète banshee au moins tu peux
compter sur guillaume genton pas de
péter braid donne des films
benji rien à dire baba sait séduire ses
chroniqueurs aux pauvres estimé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce que tu m'as fait c'est la taille
essayaient fin de saison cyril a dîné
comme bokolo mode
[Applaudissements]
vraiment plus de saison même moi tu un
nicolas pernikoff se prend avant dans sa
gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et comme chaque semaine on finit avec la
citation signée cyril signé baba c'est
le meilleur ou si j'ai envie de revenir
l'année prochaine
c'est moi je serais heureux quand je
serai plus beau que riche ça risque pas
d'arriver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est que benjamin oleme bien oui fx on
adore le charrier et il sera de retour
demain des hommages à main autant dire
voilà que donc on sera demain dimanche
au moment où sera l'émission à 10 parce
que c'est la fin de la séance il faut
mettre un petit billet en plus son métro
cyril c'est la fin de la saison et qui
dit fin de saison dit bilan alors je
suis sorti dans la rue demander aux gens
à la france ce qu'ils pensent de vous ou
des chroniqueurs on appelle ça sous
forme de jeu on va essayer de deviner de
qui il parle
ok c'est le ba ba ou l'autre je vous
préviens on n'a pas pris les plus sympas
qu'est-ce que s'il y avait une très
belle qualité de chômage total ou non
mais vraiment sur une évolution
capillaire mais vraiment ça me paraît
que vous avez draguer sa mère ce
week-end dans celle du madrillet je vote
les chocs font balader à l'imprimé snap
banon sa mère a pris mon servent alors
pas une bouée à la passe naples et sékou
sylla je suis beaucoup en débat par watt
et pourquoi
je
c'est dur vous l'avez connu sur tender
pas trop méchant c'est rien c'est dans
la primaire quoi tu serais tombé ça fait
belle lurette ben alors
[Applaudissements]
photo ja
richie et speck rajoutons le pape à
l'honneur
[Applaudissements]
à la 40e les jeunes et les jeunes femmes
et hommes est alors descendu de la
voiture
regardez comment tu publies sa voiture
on redescend pas il a voulu faire
l'autre mais c'est ça avec une voiture
la même couleur d'ailleurs mais les
montois elbaz
il n'y a pas d'appel belge balle genton
séparé d'amel bent change encore une
troisième fois mais elle bat c'est moi
[Rires]
comme ça madame verreault
tamer a le droit aussi à regarder
non puisque vous êtes en train de dire
que c'est pour l'autre on n'est pas à
l'abri d'une belle histoire
[Applaudissements]
elle aime pas les blondes ma mère elle a
changé d'avis elle aime la virilité
ben alors je suis très choquée c'est
mieux demain ce soir
[Rires]
le théâtre l'amour
sa famille ne s'est pas une famille brad
mills elle et tous le calme est une
femme libre aussi bien dans ta mère tu
as une photo bela mais dans la foulée
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
est ce qu'avec ce n'est pas que je vais
faire tous les gens passaient hockey
durant l'année
on a du mal à jouer ce magnéto comme
arrêt devant la tombe a pas s'il est
bien tu verras
en tout cas ma mère elle attend de
chasse un prime time sur ces huit mois
maintenant je vois tu vois avec lui s'il
s'est produit par papa
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
maintenant tu seras jamais mon père
[Applaudissements]